podrían los eeuu de américa a estar
deseando que rusia invade ucrania amigos
este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a que
empleen una plataforma para practicar
inglés de forma individual con tutores
nativos especializados muy pero que muy
interesante
[Aplausos]
[Música]
moscú se ha enrocado tropas tanques
misiles y buques de guerra procedentes
de todos los distritos militares del
país han sido desplegados junto a la
frontera de ucrania todo parece listo
para una gran ofensiva el motivo
supuestamente contrarrestar el creciente
peso de la otan en la región pero y si
el resultado de esta operación fuera
exactamente el contrario al pretendido
por moscú queridos amigos amigas estoy
completamente seguro de que todos habéis
escuchado hablar mucho sobre el
conflicto entre rusia ucrania y eeuu y
la unión europea sin embargo puede que
nos hayáis hecho una pregunta
fundamental podrían los eeuu estar
deseando que finalmente se produjera la
invasión rusa de ucrania no os aseguro
que no se nos ha ido la cabeza en este
vídeo vamos a echar un vistazo a los
cuatro grandes motivos por los que para
rusia la invasión de ucrania podría ser
un tremendo error estratégico la gran
trampa a la que se enfrenta vladimir
putin atentos
[Música]
pero un momento porque antes de
continuar os quiero hablar de kemble una
plataforma para practicar y mejorar tu
inglés
gracias a ella vamos a poder terminar de
una vez por todas con la mayor pesadilla
del mundo hispano el dominio del inglés
desde tu casa o desde el lugar que tú
quieras y con tan sólo un ordenador
podrás conectarte con uno de los miles
de tutores nativos que hay en cambridge
estoy seguro de que podrás encontrar uno
que se ajuste a tus necesidades no sé
qué quieres mejorar tu inglés para los
negocios pues tendrás tutores expertos
en este tema que quieres ir a londres a
singapur o a chicago por ejemplo y lo
necesitas para viajar pues también
encontrarás tutores nativos que te
ayuden con ello necesites el inglés para
lo que lo necesites con kim li tendrás a
tu disposición una plataforma de clases
individuales para ayudarte interesante
no nos parece pues atentos porque para
conseguir tus objetivos con el inglés
ahora y hasta el 17 de febrero del 2022
que emily te regala un cupón con un 50%
de descuento en cualquier plan anual es
decir podrás aprender inglés todo el año
y seis meses te saldrán completamente
gratis y eso no es todo además ahora que
se acerca san valentín también podrás
regalarle un mes gratis a quien tú
quieras e importante todos los que
registres podréis probar de servicio
durante 10 minutos de forma
completamente gratuita y sin de
introducir ninguna tarjeta de crédito
vamos sin ningún compromiso y ojo porque
esto sí que es para siempre veas cuando
veas este vídeo de verdad si queréis
mejorar con vuestro inglés no dejéis
pasar esta oferta e introducir el código
love vp en gameplay o loft vp kit en
game liquid al seleccionar un plan para
conseguirla ya no tenéis excusa para no
aprender inglés dicho esto en un próximo
vídeo os contaremos las bazas con las
que cuenta rusia así que no te olvides
de suscribirte a visual político y darle
a la campanita y ahora si arranquemos
[Música]
pero ucraniano
queridos amigos la república de ucrania
no es precisamente un país pequeño con
más de 600.000 kilómetros cuadrados y
unos 40 millones de habitantes una
invasión rusa a gran escala sería
tremendamente costosa y no me refiero
sólo al coste de la invasión sino sobre
todo al de la ocupación me explico todo
apunta a que el ejército ucraniano pues
no tendría mucho que hacer contra las
tropas rusas por número de efectivos por
arsenal o por experiencia en combate los
más de 120 mil soldados con los que el
kremlin ha rodeado ucrania parecen
tenerlo todo para cumplir la misión con
éxito es un ejército terrestre ucraniano
que se ha vuelto mucho mejor mucho más
capaz pero los rusos serían dueños del
aire y el mar dealing with love' general
retirado de la fuerza aérea de eeuu
claro que un momento porque la
diferencia de fuerzas fue siempre mucho
mayor en afganistán y a pesar de ello
tanto la unión soviética como los
propios eeuu se enfrentaron a una guerra
interminable pues bien algo así podría
ocurrir en ucrania
[Música]
primero la invasión podría conllevar un
importante desgaste y muchas bajas para
las tropas rusas no olvidemos que bajo
los gobiernos de x 80 y de lenski el
ejército cree no ha mejorado
considerablemente más de 400.000
personas han adquirido experiencia de
combate y los eeuu y el resto de países
de la otan les han suministrado una gran
cantidad de misiles antitanques y
antiaéreos en esta línea el 1 de enero
entra en vigor la ley de resistencia
nacional que tiene el objetivo de
movilizar a 120 mil reservistas muchos
de ellos con experiencia de combate para
apoyar a los más de 200 mil efectivos
con los que cuenta a día de hoy el
ejército ucraniano
por supuesto os sobra decir que
cualquier fracaso en el frente podría
ser desastroso para el régimen político
de vladimir putin segundo la ocupación
posterior a la invasión podría agotar
tanto las arcas como las propias fuerzas
del ejército ruso porque seamos claros
cualquier intento de ocupar el país
conllevaría una fuerte resistencia y
mucha actividad de grupos insurgentes
todo el mundo se compra armas para
luchar contra los rusos tenemos muchos
clubes a los que la gente va a diario a
entrenarse miroslav guy es combatiente
en el frente del bombas movimientos que
además no lo dudéis ni un segundo serían
financiados entrenados y apoyados por la
propia otan el objetivo sería siempre
maximizar el coste económico militar y
político que una invasión tendría para
rusia eeuu consideran respaldar la
insurgencia si rusia invadió ucrania la
triste realidad es que rusia puede tomar
tanto de ucrania como quiera pero no
puede aguantar la melinda haring
subdirectora de la atlantic council
eurasia center y todo ello insisto dando
por hecho que durante la invasión pues
los rusos no sufrieran ninguna
complicación evidentemente cuanto mayor
fuera el objetivo de la invasión mayores
serían los riesgos claro que la
posibilidad de meterse en todo un
avispero es tan uno de los peligros que
esta operación plantea para rusia
atentos
[Música]
para una carrera que no puedes ganar
presta mucha atención a estas palabras
de jens stoltenberg el mismísimo
secretario general de la otan si la
intención de rusia era conseguir menos o
tan cerca de su frontera ha conseguido
exactamente lo contrario y si vuelven a
usar la fuerza contra ucrania
conseguirán aún más otan en sus
fronteras jens stoltenberg secretario
general de la otan hasta ahora la excusa
que ha utilizado una y otra y otra vez
el kremlin para amenazar la soberanía de
ucrania ha sido la de querer frenar la
expansión de la otan en el frente
oriental pues el resultado de un
invasión puede ser exactamente el
contrario por tres motivos primero la
invasión de ucrania puede provocar que
al menos dos nuevos países sobre efe y
finlandia terminen uniéndose al tratado
del atlántico norte para garantizar su
seguridad y como mínimo la cooperación
de estos dos países con la otan sería en
cualquier caso reforzada lo que por
cierto es precisamente lo que han venido
haciendo durante los últimos años a
medida que hemos visto una rusia más y
más agresiva suecia y finlandia han
incrementado la cooperación bilateral
con eeuu suecia se dio cuenta de la
amenaza de moscú el viernes santo- de
2013 cuando aviones militares rusos
simularon una operación de bombardeo a
gran escala sobrevolando estocolmo
william al ver que director de
estrategia tecnología y control de
armamento en el international institute
for strategic studies en segundo lugar
una operación militar en ucrania
volvería a cuestionar a la mayoría de
los integrantes de la otan especialmente
a los países del centro y del este de
europa que se abrazarían sin dudarlo a
washington y al proyecto de seguridad
atlántica sería por así decirlo la forma
de volver a poner en forma a la otan
queridos amigos amigas podemos decir que
putin sería la otan lo que las espinacas
a popeye
[Música]
y en tercer lugar quizás la cuestión más
importante de todas la invasión de
ucrania muy probablemente terminaría
desatando una enorme carrera
armamentística en el nuevo telón de
acero que se está formando en el este de
europa una carrera que rusia simple y
llanamente no puede ganar porque los
países europeos amigos tienen economías
mucho más ricas y accesos a tecnologías
más avanzadas así que si hace 30 años la
unión soviética cayó exhausta tras una
enorme carrera militar con los eeuu
ahora esa misma situación se puede
volver a reproducir de momento países
como polonia estonia o suecia ya han
anunciado presupuestos militares récords
para reconstruir y mejorar sus fuerzas
armadas
pues con una invasión podríamos esperar
prácticamente lo mismo de la inmensa
mayor parte de países de europa ofrece
aumentar el gasto en defensa un 40 por
ciento ante el temor a rusia polonia
planea reforzar el ejército en medio de
las amenazas de bielorrusia y rusia el
ejército polaco anunciado planes para
duplicar con creces su número de tropas
el presupuesto de defensa estonio para
2022 será el más grande de la historia y
son tan sólo tres ejemplos sumarle a
todo esto un mayor despliegue de tropas
y equipos de países como eeuu o el reino
unido en otras palabras putin puede
lograr lo que washington no ha
conseguido en un montón de años que los
presupuestos militares duro para superen
el 2% del pib anual es decir que si el
propósito de putin era frenar a la otan
el resultado de una invasión sería
exactamente el opuesto y sabéis que no
hemos hecho más que empezar porque aquí
no termina ni mucho menos las pérdidas
potenciales para rusia atentos
[Música]
la gran baza rusa que puede desaparecer
con el gas hemos topado amigos durante
la guerra fría la unión soviética no
dejó de vender gas a europa incluyendo a
europa occidental la venta de gas ha
sido para rusia un importante fuente de
divisas durante las últimas décadas
quizás precisamente por esa condición de
proveedor confiable y barato los países
europeos no han tenido mucho
inconveniente en incrementar su
dependencia del gas ruso hasta niveles
récords aproximadamente un tercio de
todo el gas que se consume en europa
procede de rusia
[Música]
sin embargo ahora eso podría empezar a
cambiar las reducciones en el suministro
y el uso del gas con fines políticos
podrían significar el fin de la
complacencia europea sobre todo si tras
una invasión rusa de ucrania se
reproduce la tensión entre las dos
partes y ojo porque ésta ha sido un
viejo anhelo de eeuu que no quiere ni
por asomo que sus aliados de la otan
sean rehenes energéticos de moscú
[Música]
además no lo diremos eeuu aspira a
convertirse en un importante exportador
de gas natural licuado gas que en parte
podría suplir las importaciones de rusia
estamos colaborando con gobiernos y
operadores del mercado en el suministro
de volúmenes adicionales de gas natural
a europa desde diversas fuentes en todo
el mundo declaración conjunta de joe
biden yours hula von der leyen de esta
forma a la consecuencia automática de
una invasión podría ser la cancelación
del norte string 2 y la búsqueda urgente
de fuentes alternativas fuentes quizás
más caras pero mucho mejores en términos
de seguridad en esta misma línea por
ejemplo países como polonia o estonia ya
han confirmado que quieren construir
nuevas centrales nucleares así que a
medio plazo si las economías europeas se
toman en serio lo de buscar alternativas
al gas procedente de rusia incluso
aunque fuera parcialmente el golpe
amigos para la economía rusa sería
simple y llanamente devastador tened en
cuenta que el petróleo y el gas suponen
dos tercios de todas las exportaciones
rusas y aproximadamente la mitad del
presupuesto federal en esa situación
rusia no tendría más remedio que
realizar enormes inversiones para
venderle gas a precio de saldo a los
chinos es decir que la invasión podría
terminar erosionando una de las grandes
bazas políticas y económicas que hoy por
y rusia en 10 años la situación
energética de la vieja europa podría ser
muy pero que muy diferente a la de hoy
en día y por cierto hablando de impacto
económico ojo con el cuarto gran motivo
por el que la invasión rusa de ucrania
podría ser un colosal error
[Música]
[Aplausos]
sanciones sanciones y más sanciones
en esta ocasión el jugo diplomático está
desarrollándose básicamente así moscú
amenaza con invadir ucrania y entonces
la respuesta de washington y el resto de
grandes capitales europeas pasa por
amenazar con más y más sanciones
económicas y vuelta a empezar lo que por
otra parte no resulta nada nuevo
desde que rusia se anexionó crime a la
comunidad internacional ha castigado al
país de vladimir putin con un montón de
sanciones fundamentalmente de tres tipos
sanciones financieras sanciones contra
oligarcas cercanos al kremlin y algunas
restricciones a la compra de tecnología
esta es una estrategia que puso en
marcha a barack obama y que luego ha
sido ampliada por donald trump y joe
biden
[Música]
si existe cierto debate sobre la
efectividad de las sanciones con las que
hasta ahora se ha castigado rusia sin
embargo lo cierto es que desde que se
pusieron en marcha las sanciones la
economía rusa va de mal en peor desde el
2014 apenas ha crecido una media del 0,3
por ciento anual y si ya se lo que
muchos estaréis pensando hombre enrique
es que este tiempo coincidió con el
hundimiento del precio del petróleo pues
sí pero no se trata sólo del crecimiento
económico
[Música]
desde que se aprobaran las sanciones
contra la economía rusa la entrada de
inversión extranjera directa se desplomó
a menos de la mitad para que os hagáis
una idea esto supone que entre el 2014 y
2019 por ejemplo rusia perdió unos 169
mil millones de dólares en inversiones
productivas eso no es todo si a esto le
sumamos con los mercados de capitales se
cerraron en gran medida tanto para el
gobierno como sobre todo para las
empresas rusas el resultado es que tanto
los niveles de inversión como de
productividad han ido de mal en peor
entre otras cosas esto es lo que explica
porque durante estos años el ingreso
disponible de los rusos se ha desplomado
más de un 10 por ciento y porque la tasa
de cambio del rublo con el dólar cayó
más de un 50 por ciento
[Música]
pero queréis un ejemplo concreto pues
fijaos indonesia argelia y egipto acaban
de renunciar a comprar en su coche 35s
una de las joyas de la aviación militar
rusa y uno de los elementos clave del
catálogo militar del país pero la
pregunta es por qué están cancelando los
pedidos pues precisamente porque por
culpa de las sanciones rusia no puede
importar componentes vitales para la
aviónica y el radar de este avión lo que
afecta considerablemente a sus
capacidades así que no lo quieren pero
pese a todas las sanciones que se han
establecido hasta el momento han sido
más bien modestas lo que ahora podría
cambiar
el paquete de sanciones que estarían
barajando eeuu y la unión europea si
rusia finalmente invade ucrania va
muchísimo más allá por ejemplo se habla
de grandes controles de exportación de
sacar a los bancos rusos del sistema
internacional de comunicación bancaria
el sistema swift de cortar por completo
la financiación a los bancos y al
gobierno ruso o incluso entre muchas
otras de medidas tan agresivas como ésta
maiden amenaza con prohibir el dólar a
los bancos rusos en eeuu dijo que podría
impedir que las instituciones
financieras rusas comerciales en dólares
y moscú invade ucrania es decir se
trataría no sólo de dañar la economía
rusa sino sobre todo de impedir su
desarrollo y esto es importante porque
amigos amigas no nos engañemos a largo
plazo un país con menos recursos es un
país condenado a ser mucho menos
poderoso en washington lo saben y esta
puede ser la oportunidad perfecta para
hacerlo sería un desastre una pesadilla
para el mercado financiero interno ser
gay y alexanco es vicepresidente primero
del banco central de rusia de momento
las empresas internacionales que se
estaban planteando invertir en rusia han
congelado o cancelado estos proyectos la
bolsa de moscú ha caído con fuerza y la
prima de riesgo se ha disparado son por
así decirlo las primeras consecuencias
del arriesgada apuesta que hay moscú
putin se ha seguido en su juego con
ucrania robert gates el secretario de
defensa de eeuu ahora bien quiere decir
todo esto que no habrá invasión para
nada
[Música]
y la estrategia diplomática seguida por
eeuu y la otan en cierto modo ha
acorralado a putin que solo va a tener
tres opciones retirarse humillado pactar
un acuerdo que pueda vender en casa pero
sin sacar nada destacado y haciendo a su
vez confesiones accidentes o tercero
invadir ucrania posiblemente mediante
una invasión parcial tal y como os hemos
contado en las claves de la semana el
boletín que recibís todos los que nos
apoyáis en patrón en este caso puede que
las consecuencias fueran graduales en
función de cómo de grande fuera la
invasión ese está siendo seguramente el
cálculo que están haciendo en moscú
incluso puede que la acción rusa se
limite a reconocer la independencia de
los territorios controlados por las
fuerzas prorrusas en el donbass al fin y
al cabo si putin hubiera querido invadir
ucrania lo normal es que ya lo hubiera
hecho las tropas rusas llevan meses
estacionadas en el frente no tiene
sentido esperar a que sus adversarios
refuercen sus defensas no nos parece y
ojo porque ésta es por ejemplo la idea
que defiende el propio gobierno
ucraniano que una y otra vez afirma que
ellos no ven por ningún lado un riesgo
real de que rusia lleve a cabo una gran
invasión en el país
[Música]
sea como sea todo parece indicar que en
esta ocasión washington está dispuesto a
jugar fuerte putin un líder acostumbrado
a realizar apuestas arriesgadas podría
haber sobreestimado esta vez sus
posibilidades de victoria en todo este
embrollo ahora el resultado es que haga
lo que haga moscú en casi todos los
escenarios y el ganador más probable es
precisamente eeuu pensarlo bien hablamos
de un país que no tiene nada que perder
y sí mucho que ganar en toda esta
historia está amigos puede ser la gran
trampa a la que se enfrenta vladimir
putin pero dicho esto turno para ti
crees que el presidente ruso ha
sobreestimado sus fuerzas o crees que al
final se saldrá con la suya que crees
que puede ganar rusia invadiendo ucrania
cual tendría que ser la respuesta de la
otan dejándonos por aquí abajo tus
opiniones y ahora hemos debate y ahora
sí y si este vídeo te resultó
interesante no olvides darle a like y
suscribirte a visual político una vez
más muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]